[Musique]
bien alors c'est un travail où on a
écoute attentivement les gens qui
parlent et après on va résumer ce qu'ils
ont dit pour qu'on puisse finalement
retracer ce qu'ils ont dit donc c'est
pas forcément illustré mais ça aussi ça
crée des ponts bêtes et si on le fait
pour soi-même donc peut-être il y aurait
eu ici un sketch notaire
donc c'est les gens qui dessinent
pendant qu'ils écoutent et puis ils sont
dans le public voilà donc ça c'est en
petit ce que je fais c'est une graphique
recording donc du coup je le fais pour
un public et ça peut être dans lors
d'une conférence ça peut être aussi lors
d'un
workshop pour une entreprise qui ont
envie de clarifier des idées voilà
et puis donc finalement ça met en images
quelque chose il y a une côté objective
comme il y a aussi un côté subjectif je
gère ça dépend un peu ce que donc dans
quel contexte je suis et puis pour qui
je travaille et puis là bon je me sente
plus ou moins libre libre je dois dire
mais j'avais quand même envie de pouvoir
disons pouvoir vous montrer comment on
peut maintenant retracer et en fait j'ai
un métier que je te l'a une des
premières à pratiquer tout cela en
Suisse donc être graphique record je
l'ai appris par internet et puis j'avais
juste envie de raconter cette anecdote
parce que j'ai dû dépasser mes limites
donc je forme des gens dans ces domaines
là pour ça j'avais créé un petit marché
donc des gens qui m'ont dit d'accord on
a PowerPoint on va tester un peu
qu'est-ce que l'image peut nous apporter
le dessin voilà et puis du coup on m'a
téléphoné puis il m'a dit ah j'ai on a
besoin un graphique record est-ce que
vous le faites du nom je l'ai jamais
fait mais je peux revenir chez vous ah
non alors on veut pas de vous alors
quelques semaines plus tard il me
téléphone oui on a besoin de graphique
record est-ce que vous avez déjà fait et
je dis toujours
c'est mon métier et puis on a dit super
alors on vous engage du coup j'avais mon
premier mandat et puis après je me suis
dit ok maintenant j'ai ta dans mon bain
mais tu dois aussi assurer alors je me
suis mis sur Internet et puis j'ai
trouvé des anciens métiers qui existent
ou existe aux États-Unis là il faut
mettre maintenant vers 10 ans 15 ans en
arrière et puis
et du coup je commence à dessiner à
dessiner puis à me dire à regarder sur
internet mais comment qu'est-ce qui est
le produit je me suis fait une espèce de
protocole comment je vais arriver à
écouter et puis à faire ça et puis du
coup bah j'ai comme ça je suis devenu la
première à faire du graphique recording
en Suisse maintenant je suis de loin
plus la seule mais je suis certainement
la plus âgée voilà alors et puis moi
j'ai plein de collègues maintenant
autour de mon plan collègue on est
peut-être 15 à le faire en Suisse et
puis donc c'est des gens super sympa
on sent beaucoup on se donne du Jobs
entre nous on a une belle petite
communauté et puis on a tous nos
spécificités j'ai donc la mienne c'est
faire du graphique recording mais aussi
transmettre ça disons comment aimer à
dessiner même si on n'aime pas si on
pense qu'on ne peut pas dessiner voilà
alors si jamais vous voulez dépasser vos
limites de ce côté-là donc c'est moi qui
peut ouvrir ses portes à ça voilà et
puis
juste pour pour revenir un petit basse
qu'on a on a fait je vais commencer
ici donc le parcours commence ici à
bulle avec vous on publique avec je me
souviens pas le nom
Hervé et on a passé ici donc sur
Michael kam avec son amour pour la poule
on a continué avec Anne-Christine qui
est bien au froid pendant un moment ce
qui lui a amené aussi à se poser des
questions faute et tous toujours
dépasser les limites donc ça mis un
petit réflexion par rapport à ça arrivé
chez Brigitte et Laurent qui ont passé
les 7 mois au Népal grâce au covid et
qui sont après
revenus à se dire mais c'est assez sympa
le finalement ne pas être dans la
surconsommation on peut très bien vivre
avec ça et puis peut-être en tant que
riche consommateur est-ce qu'on va
dépasser nos limites ce côté là
on continue
avec une histoire locale mais qui a
beaucoup plus qu'une histoire locale qui
finalement nous amène dans l'histoire
avec H majuscule et ou malheureusement
les femmes passent à la trappe
et que les hommes ont les on leur donne
des noms de rue et puis des noms de
magasins voilà à nous faire réfléchir un
petit peu comment changer cet état de
fait on passe sur sa chaîne mais avec sa
passion de courir et puis j'adore et
aussi il dit voilà je cours pour mon
plaisir et c'est pas pour me faire
souffrir et qui nous invite finalement à
dépasser nos limites mais avec quelque
chose qu'on aime et on termine avec
l'opercule je dû regarder trois fois ce
que c'était
un ou une opercule maintenant je sais et
que finalement aussi nous a aussi amener
à se dire si je veux passer je veux
franchir mes limites c'est pour quel
objectif ça vaut le coup voilà alors
donc encore une fois vite résumer ce que
nous avons entendu de ces riches des
séries
[Musique]
paroles de tout le monde voilà merci
[Applaudissements]